So, I want you to think about how we should do modularize our search engine.
Here's all the functions that we defined. Our goal is to figure out a way to
group these functions into a small number of modules, that will have a narrow
interface that will make sense and that will help us manage the complexity of
the search engine. Let me give you a few choices. So, choice A will have two
modules. The first one will contain will contain the functions getnexttarget,
get_all _targets, addpageto _index, addtoindex, crawl_web, and
compute_ranks. The second module will contain the lookup function, as well as
lucky_search, quicksort_pages, and ordered_search. For choice B, we'll group the
first six functions in one module. And we'll group the next four in another
module. And for choice C, we're going to group getnexttarget, getalllinks,
addpageto_index, addtoindex, and crawl_web in one module. We'll make lookup
its own module. And we'll group the remaining functions in a third module. Which
one of these three do you think would be best? Answering this is going to
require some thought, and maybe a little speculation. And it might be possible
that it would make a good case for more than one option. But I think there is
one that's clearly best here and see if you can identify which one it is.